Willkommen zurück bei „Quanteninformation und -berechnung verstehen". Mein Name ist John Wattress und ich bin der technische Direktor für Bildung bei IBM
Quantum. Dies ist die 16. und letzte Lektion der Reihe, und das Thema dieser Lektion ist fehlertolerantes Quanten-
computing. Im Verlauf der drei vorherigen Lektionen haben wir mehrere Beispiele von Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes gesehen, die Quantenfehler erkennen und uns ermöglichen, sie zu
korrigieren, solange nicht zu viele davon auftreten. Wenn wir Fehlerkorrektur für das Quantencomputing nutzen wollen, gibt es jedoch noch viele
Probleme, mit denen wir uns auseinandersetzen müssen, darunter die Tatsache, dass unsere Quanten-gates, Messungen und Zustands-
präparationen selbst wahrscheinlich fehlerhaft sind. Wenn wir also beispielsweise eine Fehlerkorrektur an einem
oder mehreren qubits durchführen wollen, die mit einem Quantenfehlerkorrekturcode kodiert wurden, dann müssen wir das mit gates und Messungen tun, die selbst
eine Chance haben, nicht korrekt zu funktionieren. Das bedeutet nicht nur, dass wir Fehler möglicherweise nicht erkennen oder korrigieren, sondern auch
neue Fehler einführen könnten. Außerdem müssen wir die eigentlichen Berechnungen, die uns interessieren, ebenfalls mit gates durchführen, die nicht
perfekt sind. Und wir können es uns keinesfalls leisten, Quanteninformation zum Zweck der Berechnung zu dekodieren und sie dann
anschließend neu zu kodieren, weil Fehler auftreten könnten, wenn der Schutz eines Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes fehlt.
Das bedeutet, dass wir herausfinden müssen, wie wir Quanten-gates direkt auf logischen qubits ausführen können, die nie ohne den
Schutz eines Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes sind. Das ist eine hohe Anforderung, aber es ist bekannt, dass solange das Rauschpegel
unter einem bestimmten Schwellenwert liegt, es tatsächlich möglich ist, beliebig große Quantenberechnungen zuverlässig mit verrauschter Hardware durchzuführen, zumindest
in der Theorie. Diesen wichtigen Sachverhalt werden wir später in der Lektion besprechen. Hier ist ein kurzer Überblick über die
Lektion. Wir beginnen mit einem grundlegenden Modell für fehlertolerantes Quantencomputing, einschließlich einer kurzen Diskussion
von Rauschmodellen sowie einer allgemeinen Methode zur fehlertoleranten Implementierung eines Quanten-circuits
tolerant. Danach widmen wir uns dem Problem der Fehlerausbreitung in fehlertoleranten Quanten-circuits und wie man sie
kontrolliert. Insbesondere werde ich transversale gate-Implementierungen besprechen, die eine sehr einfache Möglichkeit bieten, die Fehlerausbreitung zu kontrollieren,
obwohl es eine grundlegende Einschränkung gibt, die uns daran hindert, diese Methode
ausschließlich zu verwenden. Ich werde auch eine andere Methode vorstellen, die sogenannte magische Zustände verwendet, die einen anderen Weg zur Kontrolle der Fehler-
ausbreitung in fehlertoleranten Quanten-circuits bietet. Obwohl es nicht die einzige bekannte Methode ist, schließt die Lektion
mit einer recht allgemeinen Diskussion des Schwellenwerttheorems ab, auf das ich gerade eben verwiesen habe.
Dieses Theorem besagt, dass beliebig große Quanten-circuits zuverlässig implementiert werden können, solange die Fehlerrate aller beteiligten Komponenten
unter einem bestimmten endlichen Schwellenwert liegt. Im Allgemeinen hängt dieser Schwellenwert
vom verwendeten Fehlerkorrekturcode sowie von den spezifischen Entscheidungen ab, die wir für fehlertolerante Implementierungen von
Quanten-gates und Messungen treffen, nicht jedoch von der Größe des implementierten circuits. Und das gibt uns einen guten Grund zu glauben, dass groß angelegte
Quantenberechnungen eines Tages Realität werden. Wir beginnen mit der Diskussion eines grundlegenden Modells für fehlertolerantes Quanten-
computing, das auf Quanten-circuits und Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes basiert. Für diese Diskussion
stellen wir uns vor, dass wir einen Quanten-circuit haben, den wir implementieren möchten, wie den hier gezeigten. Dieser
ist zufällig ein Teleportations-circuit einschließlich der Vorbereitung des EBIT. Aber die Details sind für diese Diskussion nicht wirklich wichtig. Du kannst dir vorstellen, dass
dies ein beliebiger anderer Quanten-circuit ist, möglicherweise ein viel größerer circuit, der Zustandspräparationen, unitäre
Operationen und Messungen enthält. Dieser circuit stellt natürlich ein Ideal dar, und eine tatsächliche
Implementierung davon wird nicht perfekt sein. Die naheliegende Frage ist, was dabei möglicherweise schiefgehen könnte.
Nun, es gibt eine ganze Menge, das schiefgehen könnte. Zum Beispiel werden die Zustandsinitialisierungen generell nicht
perfekt sein. Natürlich werden die unitären gates nicht perfekt sein, und die
Messungen auch nicht. Außerdem sind die qubits selbst anfällig für Rauschen, einschließlich Dekohärenz, an jedem Punkt in
der Berechnung, auch wenn diese qubits gerade nichts tun und nur Quanteninformation speichern. Mit anderen Worten, so gut wie
alles könnte schiefgehen. Es gibt jedoch eine Ausnahme – oder zumindest ist das eine typische Annahme –
und zwar, dass alle klassischen Berechnungen, die beteiligt sind, wahrscheinlich nicht fehlerhaft sein werden, weil für alle praktischen Zwecke
klassische Berechnungen im Wesentlichen perfekt sind. Wenn wir also zum Beispiel einen klassischen Matching-Algorithmus ausführen, um
Korrekturen für Surface-Code-Fehler zu berechnen, müssen wir uns keine Sorgen machen, dass diese klassische Berechnung fehlerhaft sein könnte. Aber alles, was direkt
Quanteninformation beinhaltet, könnte es sein. Natürlich brauchen wir ein präzises Modell, durch das wir
Wahrscheinlichkeiten für verschiedene Fehler zuweisen können. Und wenn wir wollten, könnten wir so ein kompliziertes Modell entwickeln, wie wir es für sinnvoll halten, um hoffentlich das widerzuspiegeln, was
tatsächlich in der Realität passiert. Wenn das Modell jedoch zu kompliziert ist, könnte es schwierig oder unmöglich werden, damit zu arbeiten oder
interessante Aussagen darüber zu machen. Ein sehr einfaches Beispiel eines Rauschmodells, das oft betrachtet wird,
ist das unabhängige stochastische Rauschmodell, bei dem Fehler oder Ausfälle, die verschiedene Komponenten zu verschiedenen
Zeitpunkten betreffen – also an verschiedenen Stellen im circuit – unabhängig voneinander sind.
Wir könnten zum Beispiel sagen, dass jedes gate mit einer bestimmten Wahrscheinlichkeit versagt, dass Bit-Flips und Phasen-Flips gespeicherte qubits mit einer anderen
Wahrscheinlichkeit pro Zeiteinheit betreffen und so weiter. Die Annahme ist aber, dass es keine Korrelation zwischen verschiedenen
Fehlern gibt. Du könntest gegen dieses Modell einwenden, dass es wahrscheinlich einige Korrelationen zwischen
Fehlern geben wird. Es gibt zum Beispiel wahrscheinlich eine kleine Chance eines katastrophalen Fehlers, der alle qubits auf einmal auslöscht.
Oder, was vielleicht wahrscheinlicher ist, es könnte Fehler geben, die lokalisiert sind, aber dennoch mehrere Komponenten betreffen.
Niemand bestreitet das. Dennoch stellt dieses Modell eine einfache Ausgangsbasis dar, die im
Wesentlichen die Idee verkörpert, dass die Natur unvorhersehbar ist, aber nicht böswillig und nicht versucht, Quanten-
berechnungen absichtlich zu sabotieren. Es gibt andere, wohl realistischere Rauschmodelle, die oft betrachtet werden. Und unabhängig vom
gewählten Modell gilt: Wenn sich herausstellt, dass unser Modell uns in die Irre führt und wir Neues über die Fehler in
dem System, mit dem wir arbeiten, lernen, können wir natürlich andere Fehlermodelle formulieren und betrachten. Als Nächstes schauen wir uns
eine grundlegende Strategie zur fehlertoleranten Implementierung von Quanten-circuits an. Betrachten wir also einen gegebenen
logischen Quanten-circuit, also einen idealen Quanten-circuit, den wir ausführen möchten. Wir könnten zum Beispiel denselben circuit wie
zuvor betrachten, der jetzt ein wenig gestreckt ist, weil wir etwas mehr Platz für die fehlertolerante Implementierung benötigen. Zunächst
werden die Zustandspräparationen, unitären gates und Messungen nicht direkt als einzelne gates oder als
einzelne qubit-Messungen oder Zustandspräparationen durchgeführt, sondern durch sogenannte Gadgets,
die jeweils mehrere qubits und mehrere Operationen umfassen können. In diesem Diagramm habe ich
Das habe ich veranschaulicht, indem ich lila Kästen um diese Dinge gezeichnet habe. Und du kannst dir diese lila Kästen wie kleine circuits oder Operationen vorstellen, die
lediglich durch den Zustand der Zustandspräparation oder des gate gekennzeichnet sind, den wir implementieren wollen. Zweitens müssen wir
die qubits mithilfe eines Fehlerkorrekturcodes schützen. Es werden also nicht die logischen qubits selbst sein, die diese verschiedenen Gadgets verbinden, sondern die Gadgets wirken auf
die physischen qubits, die diese logischen qubits kodieren. Und es ist wichtig zu betonen, dass die logischen qubits, um die wir uns
kümmern, niemals exponiert werden, d. h. dass diese logischen qubits ihr gesamtes Dasein damit verbringen, durch den jeweiligen
Quantenfehlerkorrekturcode, den wir verwenden, geschützt zu werden. Und schließlich führen wir Fehlerkorrektur an unseren kodierten qubits
wiederholt während der gesamten Berechnung durch, im Grunde immer wenn wir eine Gelegenheit dazu haben. Und es ist äußerst wichtig, dass wir das
tun. Intuitiv betrachtet beginnt sich, wenn Fehler auftreten, Zufälligkeit oder Unbestimmtheit im Zustand unserer
qubits aufzubauen, und wir müssen ständig daran arbeiten, diese Zufälligkeit oder Entropie zu entfernen. Und das geschieht durch Fehlerkorrektur.
Du kannst dir diese Fehlerkorrekturschritte also ein bisschen wie kleine logische Kühlschränke oder Wärmepumpen vorstellen, die
es den logischen qubits ermöglichen, kalt zu bleiben, damit die Berechnung korrekt funktionieren kann.
Sobald all diese Entscheidungen getroffen wurden – also die Auswahl aller Gadgets sowie des Codes – und ein bestimmtes Rauschmodell vorausgesetzt, gibt es eine
grundlegende Frage, die wir uns stellen können: Hilft das tatsächlich? Verbessern wir die Dinge, oder
verschlechtern wir sie? Wenn es zu viel Rauschen gibt, könnte es gut sein, dass wir die Dinge verschlechtern,
genau wie der 9-Qubit-Shore-Code die Dinge verschlechtert, wenn die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit zu hoch ist.
Aber wenn das Rauschen unter einem bestimmten Schwellenwert liegt, dann bringt uns all diese Extraarbeit irgendwohin. Und wie wir gegen Ende der Lektion besprechen werden,
eröffnen sich Wege für eine weitere Reduzierung des Fehlers. In diesem Teil der Lektion werden wir die Fehlerausbreitung in fehlertoleranten
Quanten-circuits mit der grundlegenden Struktur besprechen, die ich gerade beschrieben habe. Dies stellt sich als ein
zentrales Problem heraus, denn wenn es uns nicht gelingt, die Fehlerausbreitung zu kontrollieren, werden Fehler unsere Fehler-
korrekturbemühungen schnell überwältigen. Aber wenn wir die Ausbreitung von Fehlern kontrollieren können, dann hat unser Code eine viel bessere Chance,
Schritt zu halten, sodass Fehler schnell genug korrigiert werden können, damit unsere Berechnungen
funktionieren. Der Ausgangspunkt für diese Diskussion ist die Erkenntnis, dass Zwei-Qubit-gates oder Mehr-Qubit-gates
im Allgemeinen Fehler propagieren können, auch wenn sie korrekt funktionieren.
Betrachte zum Beispiel ein C-Not-gate. Und nehmen wir an, dass ein X-Fehler auf dem Steuer-qubit vor dem C-Not-gate
auftritt. Nun, ein X-Fehler funktioniert genau wie ein X-gate. Und wir stellen fest, dass
der circuit auf der linken Seite äquivalent zum dem auf der rechten Seite ist, wo X-Fehler auf beiden qubits nach dem C-
Not auftreten. Das ist eine Fehlerausbreitung, denn die ungünstige Position des X-Fehlers auf der linken Seite verwandelt ihn effektiv in
zwei X-Fehler auf der rechten Seite. Und daran werden wir nie vorbeikommen. Solange wir C-Not-gates verwenden, wird es immer
eine Chance geben, dass kurz davor ein X-Fehler auf dem Steuer-qubit auftritt, der sich dann zu zwei X-Fehlern
danach fortpflanzt. Aber wie wir sehen werden, solange wir Schritte unternehmen, um den Schaden zu begrenzen, den dies verursacht, wird es gut gehen. Und übrigens
tritt dasselbe Phänomen auf, wenn wir einen Z-Fehler auf dem Ziel-qubit kurz vor einem C-Not haben. Und das haben wir
bereits besprochen, und du kannst diese Gleichheiten überprüfen, indem du einfach die Multiplikationen durchführst, oder du kannst sie mit
Qiskit überprüfen. Das Fazit ist, dass dies in beiden Fällen korrelierte Fehler auf mehreren qubits verursacht. Und natürlich sollten wir
nicht vergessen, dass die C-Not-gates selbst auch fehlerhaft sein könnten, was ebenfalls korrelierte
Fehler verursachen kann. Erschwerend kommt hinzu, dass nachfolgende Zwei-Qubit-gates diese Fehler noch weiter ausbreiten könnten.
Zum Beispiel, wenn wir drei C-Not-gates wie diese haben – genau wie wir es beim Messen von X-Stabilisatorgeneratoren finden – dann kann sich ein einzelner Fehler
schnell auf mehrere qubits ausbreiten. Und wenn das innerhalb eines einzelnen Code-Blocks geschieht – also einer Gruppe von
qubits, die zusammen ein logisches qubit kodieren –, hat der von uns gewählte Fehlerkorrekturcode keine
Chance, weil Codes so konzipiert sind, Fehler mit geringem Gewicht zu korrigieren, nicht Fehler mit hohem Gewicht wie diesen hier.
Und das ist etwas, das wir wirklich im Vordergrund behalten müssen, wenn wir über die Gadgets und die
Fehlerkorrekturschritte in fehlertoleranten Quanten-circuits nachdenken. Der einfachste bekannte Weg, die Fehlerausbreitung in fehlertoleranten
Quanten-circuits zu reduzieren, ist die transversale Implementierung von gates – was das bedeutet, werde ich
gleich erklären. Lass uns also die Abbildung unserer fehlertoleranten circuit-Implementierung auf dem Bildschirm belassen, einfach als visuelle Hilfe.
Die Idee hier ist, dass für einige Quantenfehlerkorrekturcodes bestimmte gates transversal implementiert werden können, was
bedeutet, sie mithilfe von Gadgets zu implementieren, die Tensorprodukte von Operationen sind, wobei jede Operation nur auf einer
einzelnen qubit-Position innerhalb jedes Code-Blocks wirkt. Das lässt sich am leichtesten anhand von Beispielen erklären. Das erste und
wohl einfachste Beispiel sind transversale Implementierungen von Pauli-gates.
Die Idee ist, dass wir Gadgets für jedes der gates in unserem circuit erstellen möchten. Und in allen Fällen operieren diese Gadgets
auf Code-Blöcken, wie wir es bei den X- und Z-gates am Ende unseres Teleportations-circuits sehen. Natürlich können wir
nicht dekodieren, ein Pauli-gate anwenden und dann neu kodieren, weil das ein logisches qubit ungeschützt ließe und Fehler
sich infolge der Neukodierung innerhalb des Code-Blocks ausbreiten könnten.
Zum Glück müssen wir das nicht tun, solange wir einen Stabilisatorcode verwenden, denn jeder Stabilisatorcode erlaubt es, Pauli-
Operationen direkt auf unsere logischen qubits anzuwenden. Und tatsächlich können wir das mit einem Tensorprodukt von Pauli-gates
auf den physischen qubits tun, die für die Kodierung verwendet werden.
Wenn wir zum Beispiel den 3x3-Oberflächencode betrachten, der am Ende der vorherigen Lektion erwähnt wurde, können wir X- und Z-gates auf dem logischen
qubit implementieren, das durch diesen Code kodiert ist, indem wir X- und Z-gates zusammen mit Identitätsgates in den Mustern tensorn, die
hier vorgeschlagen werden. Das ist eine transversale Implementierung dieser gates, weil jede dieser einzelnen gate-
Operationen nur auf einer einzelnen qubit-Position innerhalb jedes Code-Blocks wirkt.
Wir verwenden hier nur Einzel-Qubit-gates, also ist es in gewisser Weise trivial, aber in jedem Fall werden Gadgets wie dieses keine Fehler
propagieren. Nun könnte jedes der einzelnen gates in einem solchen Gadget versagen, und das wird Fehler einführen, aber wir werden
immer sofort nach jedem Gadget eine Fehlerkorrektur durchführen. Und solange die Fehlerrate
niedrig genug ist, wird der Fehlerkorrekturcode diese Fehler korrigieren.
Und wie gesagt, das ist für Pauli-gates bei jedem Stabilisatorcode immer möglich.
Obwohl du das richtige Muster von Pauli-gates in den Gadgets identifizieren musst, um die gewünschte logische Pauli-Operation korrekt zu implementieren.
Für ein weiteres Beispiel, das Zwei-Qubit-gates beinhaltet, können wir diesmal transversale Implementierungen betrachten
von C-not-gates. Insbesondere können wir für jeden CSS-Code immer ein C-not-gate
zwischen zwei logischen qubits implementieren, indem wir einfach C-not-gates auf entsprechenden Paaren physischer
qubits ausführen. Und das erfüllt die Bedingung der Transversalität, weil jedes dieser einzelnen C-not-gates nur
auf einer einzigen qubit-Position innerhalb jedes Code-Blocks wirkt. Zum Beispiel wirkt das erste C-not-gate nur auf den obersten qubit
innerhalb jedes Code-Blocks. Das zweite C-not-gate wirkt nur auf den zweitobersten qubit und so
weiter. In diesem Fall könnte eine Fehlerausbreitung auftreten, weil C-not-gates Fehler ausbreiten und es keine
Möglichkeit gibt, das zu verhindern. Der entscheidende Punkt ist jedoch, dass die Fehlerausbreitung niemals innerhalb eines einzelnen Code-Blocks stattfindet. Zum Beispiel
könnte ein X-Fehler auf dem obersten qubit des oberen Code-Blocks auftreten, kurz bevor das Gadget ausgeführt wird, und das erste C-not
innerhalb des Gadgets wird diesen Fehler auf den obersten qubit im unteren Block ausbreiten. Aber die zwei resultierenden Fehler befinden sich
nun in separaten Code-Blocks. Die Fehlerkorrekturschritte, die nach dem Gadget stattfinden, können diese Fehler daher einzeln korrigieren, weil diese
Fehler nur einen einzigen qubit innerhalb jedes Code-Blocks betreffen.
Im Gegensatz dazu, wenn die Fehlerausbreitung innerhalb desselben Code-Blocks stattfinden würde, könnten wir in Schwierigkeiten geraten, weil die
Fehlerausbreitung dann einen niedriggradigen Fehler in einen höhergradigen Fehler verwandelt, den unser Code möglicherweise nicht bewältigen kann.
Diese Implementierung funktioniert nicht für Nicht-CSS-Codes, aber solange wir einen CSS-Code verwenden, können wir C-not
gates auf diese Weise immer transversal implementieren. Und als weiteres Beispiel: Jedes
Clifford-gate kann transversal für den Steane-Code implementiert werden. Und tatsächlich für jeden Farb-Code, was eines der wirklich schönen Dinge an Farb-
Codes ist. Insbesondere kann ein Hadamard-gate auf einem logischen qubit implementiert werden, indem Hadamard-gates einzeln auf
jedem der physischen qubits ausgeführt werden, und ein logisches S-gate kann nicht durch ein S-gate auf jedem qubit implementiert werden, sondern durch ein
S-Dagger-gate auf jedem physischen qubit. Das Fazit ist also, dass transversale gate-Implementierungen von Natur aus
fehlertolerant sind, weil sie Fehler niemals innerhalb eines einzelnen Code-Blocks ausbreiten, was den Fehlerkorrekturschritten eine echte Chance gibt, die
Fehler zu korrigieren, die durch die gates dieser Gadgets eingeführt oder ausgebreitet werden. Das ist großartig und es ist eine
wirklich einfache Methode, fehlertolerante Gadgets zu bauen. Es gibt verschiedene Codes, die transversale Implementierungen verschiedener gates ermöglichen, zum Beispiel
T-gates. Leider ist es für keinen nicht-trivialen Code möglich, ein
universelles gate-Set transversal zu implementieren – ein Fakt, der als Eastin-Knill-Theorem bekannt ist. Technisch gesagt,
bedeutet das: Solange unser Code eine Distanz von mindestens zwei hat, erzeugt die Menge der transversal implementierbaren gates notwendigerweise eine
diskrete Menge von Operationen bis auf eine globale Phase, und dieses Set ist daher nicht universell, weil universelle gate-
Sets notwendigerweise unendlich viele Operationen erzeugen. Ich werde den Beweis dieses Theorems nicht erklären, der einige
grundlegende Fakten über Lie-Gruppen und Lie-Algebren verwendet, die keine Voraussetzungen für diese Reihe sind. Aber die Grundidee ist,
dass unendliche Familien transversaler Operationen uns unmöglich innerhalb des Code-Raums halten können, weil minimale
Unterschiede in transversalen Operationen durch niedriggewichtige Pauli-Operationen gut approximiert werden, die der Code als
Fehler erkennt. Wir sind also sehr froh, wenn wir gates transversal implementieren können. Aber für jeden Code, den wir wählen, wissen wir, dass wir
immer einige gates haben werden, die wir auf diese Weise nicht implementieren können. Daher müssen wir nach alternativen Gadgets suchen. Durch das
Eastin-Knill-Theorem wissen wir, dass es nicht möglich ist, ein universelles Quantengate-Set transversal zu implementieren, nicht einmal
für einen bescheidenen Quanten-Fehlerkorrektur-Code mit Distanz 2. Wir müssen also andere Wege finden, um gates fehlertolerant
zu implementieren, zumindest für einige gates. Eine bekannte Methode dafür ist die Verwendung sogenannter magischer
Zustände. Für die Zwecke dieser Diskussion wollen wir uns die S- und T-gates in Erinnerung rufen, das sind
Einzel-qubit-gates, die hier auf dem Bildschirm definiert sind. Lass uns außerdem festhalten: Erstens ist S eine Clifford-Operation,
was aus unserer Definition von Clifford-Operationen folgt. Aber du kannst auch nachprüfen, dass das Konjugieren einer Pauli-Matrix mit S uns immer plus oder minus eine andere
Pauli-Matrix ergibt. Und zweitens ist T keine Clifford-Operation. Und tatsächlich ergibt die Kombination von T mit Hadamard und C-not, beides
Clifford-Operationen, ein universelles Quantengate-Set. Wir können also kein T-gate
allein mit Clifford-Operationen und Standardbasis-Messungen implementieren. Tatsächlich können wir ein T-gate mit
Clifford-Operationen und Standardbasis-Messungen implementieren, wenn wir zusätzlich eine Kopie des Zustands haben, der hier auf dem
Bildschirm gezeigt wird – nämlich das T-gate angewandt auf einen Plus-Zustand.
Dieser Zustand wird magischer Zustand genannt, obwohl er in dieser Hinsicht nicht einzigartig ist.
Der Begriff „magischer Zustand" wird auch verwendet, um verschiedene Zustände zu bezeichnen, die in Varianten dieses gesamten
Schemas eine ähnliche Rolle spielen. Zum Beispiel erledigt dieser hier gezeigte circuit die Aufgabe. Und es ist nicht allzu schwer, das zu
überprüfen. Hier ist der Anfangszustand mit dem oberen System auf der rechten Seite. Wenn wir das C-not-gate anwenden und vereinfachen, erhalten wir den
Zustand, der hier gezeigt wird.
Wenn wir also den unteren qubit messen und eine Null erhalten, was mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 passiert, führen wir die
S-gate-Korrektur nicht durch, und der Ausgang ist T angewandt auf s.
Und wenn wir eine Eins messen, was natürlich ebenfalls mit Wahrscheinlichkeit 1/2 passiert, wenden wir die S-gate-Korrektur an, und das Nettoergebnis ist,
dass der Ausgang wieder T angewandt auf s ist. Das ist übrigens nicht die einzige Möglichkeit. Es gibt andere ähnlich aussehende
circuits, die dieselbe Aufgabe erfüllen, aber das ist eine davon.
Das ist ein etwas vereinfachtes Beispiel für etwas, das als Quanten-gate-Teleportation bekannt ist, worauf ich in Lektion 4 hingewiesen habe, wo Teleportation verwendet wird,
nicht um qubits zu übertragen, sondern um gates anzuwenden. Der Bezug zur Teleportation ist hier möglicherweise nicht ganz klar, weil, wie ich
sagte, das eine vereinfachte Version ist, mit der wir auskommen können, weil T diagonal ist. Aber wenn du daran interessiert bist,
mehr zu erfahren, sind die Schlüsselwörter: Quanten-gate-Teleportation.
Und wir könnten auch etwas Ähnliches tun, um ein S-gate zu implementieren, wobei wir diesmal nur ein C-not-gate und ein Z-gate zusammen mit der Messung benötigen,
was hilfreich ist, wenn wir keine transversale Implementierung eines S-gates haben. Das ist interessant, aber es ist nicht
völlig klar, dass das tatsächlich hilft. Im Fall der T-gate-Implementierung zum Beispiel gelingt es uns,
ein T-gate auf einen Eingabezustand anzuwenden. Aber dafür scheinen wir ein T-gate auf einen Plus-Zustand anzuwenden, um einen
magischen Zustand zu erhalten. Und die Situation ist ähnlich für die S-gate-Implementierung. Der Punkt ist, dass wir
nicht unbedingt zuerst einen Plus-Zustand erstellen und dann ein T-gate anwenden müssen, um einen magischen Zustand zu erhalten. Es gibt andere mögliche Wege, diesen Zustand zu erhalten. Und
insbesondere können wir das tun, ohne uns Sorgen machen zu müssen, Fehler in die Berechnung, an der wir gerade arbeiten, auszubreiten, weil die magischen Zustände
separat erstellt werden können. Das ermöglicht eine fehlertolerante Implementierung eines T-gates, wie ich nun kurz beschreiben werde.
Zunächst werden wir den einfachen Zwei-qubit-circuit, der hier gezeigt wird, nicht direkt ausführen, sondern stattdessen diesen circuit mit
qubits ausführen, die in welchem fehlerkorrigierenden Code auch immer kodiert sind, den wir für unsere fehlertolerante Implementierung verwenden. Das bedeutet, dass die
unitären gates und die Messungen durch fehlertolerante Gadgets durchgeführt werden. Und das bedeutet, wir brauchen auch unsere
Magic States ebenfalls kodiert. Also wird alles fehlertolerant sein, solange wir Magic States in kodierter Form bekommen können.
Wir nehmen hier übrigens an, dass wir bereits ein fehlertolerantes Gadget für ein S-Gate haben. Falls
wir zum Beispiel den Steane-Code verwenden würden, könnten wir das S-Gate einfach transversal implementieren. Und für Codes, bei denen das nicht funktioniert, ist eine Option,
zunächst dieses gesamte Schema zu verwenden, um ein S-Gate fehlertolerant zu implementieren, und diese Implementierung dann hier einzusetzen.
Obwohl das nicht die einzige Option ist. Aber wie auch immer, um zur Implementierung zurückzukehren: Die wichtige Frage, die noch bleibt, ist, wie wir
einen kodierten Magic State bekommen, wenn wir noch keine fehlertolerante Implementierung eines T-Gates haben, um das
einfach zu machen. Und die Schlüsselidee ist, dass wir einen probabilistischen Prozess verwenden können, um kodierte Magic States zu erzeugen. Und wenn es
zufällig nicht klappt, ist das in Ordnung. Wir können fehlgeschlagene Versuche einfach verwerfen und es erneut versuchen.
Und das stört die Berechnung, die wir eigentlich durchführen wollen, nicht, weil die Erzeugung von Magic States separat
erfolgt. Eine typische Art und Weise, wie das gemacht wird, ist durch einen Prozess, der als Magic State Distillation bekannt ist. Und es funktioniert so:
Wir haben einen bestimmten circuit, der als Destillator bekannt ist. Wir geben in diesen Destillator eine Sammlung von verrauschten Magic
States ein und messen dann alle Ausgaben bis auf eine. Und wenn wir auf alle Messergebnisse mit dem Wert null konditionieren,
dann ist das Ergebnis ein weniger verrauschter Magic State, der dann einer der qubits-Eingaben in
einen weiteren Destillator sein kann. Und der Prozess geht weiter, bis wir entweder scheitern, weil eines der Messergebnisse nicht null ist und wir es erneut versuchen, oder wir einen Magic
State von ausreichend hoher Qualität haben, den wir sicher verwenden können, um ein T-Gate in der Berechnung zu implementieren, die uns wichtig ist.
Es gibt verschiedene bekannte Methoden, einen solchen Destillator zu bauen, aber sie funktionieren alle im Wesentlichen auf die gleiche Weise, nämlich als Decoder für Stabilisator-Codes,
was bedeutet, dass sie Umkehrungen von Kodierungs-circuits sind – was praktisch ist, da der Destillator eine Clifford-
Operation sein kann. Und schließlich ist dieser Destillationsprozess eigentlich etwas, das auf der Ebene des logischen qubit stattfindet. In der Realität wird also alles
mit Gadgets für den Destillator und die Messungen durchgeführt. Dieser Prozess muss
irgendwo beginnen. Aber solange die Rauschrate nicht zu hoch ist, ist es möglich, verrauschte, aber gut genug
Magic States zu erzeugen, um ihn zu starten. Zum Beispiel, indem man ein tatsächlich verrauschtes T-Gate auf ein qubit im Plus-Zustand anwendet und dann
dieses qubit kodiert. Das war also eine sehr abstrakte Beschreibung, aber ich hoffe, ich habe dir eine grobe Vorstellung davon gegeben, wie das funktioniert.
Es ist etwas komplizierter als das transversale Implementieren von gates, aber dennoch bietet es eine Möglichkeit, einen universellen Satz von Quanten-
gates fehlertolerant zu implementieren, was transversale Gate-Implementierungen allein nicht können. Manchmal wird behauptet,
dass der Overhead für die Verwendung von Magic States zur fehlertoleranten Implementierung von gates nach diesem Ansatz sehr hoch wäre,
wobei der weitaus größte Teil der Arbeit in die Destillation von Magic States fließt und das eigentliche Ausführen der Berechnung eher eine
Nebensache ist. Aber das ist eigentlich nicht so klar, und es gibt detaillierte Analysen, die zeigen, dass diese Methode
tatsächlich praktikabel sein könnte. Es gibt mehrere andere bekannte Schemata zur fehlertoleranten Implementierung von gates. Code-Deformation und Code-Switching sind Namen,
die mit einigen dieser Schemata verbunden sind, und neue Methoden werden weiterentwickelt und verfeinert, aber ich werde diese
Methoden in dieser Lektion nicht beschreiben. Es gibt noch ein weiteres wichtiges Problem bezüglich fehlertoleranter Implementierungen von Quanten-circuits, und
es betrifft die Fehlerkorrekturschritte selbst. Es geht also nicht darum, gates zu implementieren, sondern darum,
die eigentliche Fehlerkorrektur durchzuführen. Das Problem ist, dass wenn wir uns die einfachen circuits ansehen, die wir
erstmals in Lektion 14 gesehen haben, zum Messen von Stabilisatorgeneratoren basierend auf Phasenschätzung, stellen wir fest, dass sie
selbst nicht fehlertolerant sind, da sie potenziell dazu führen könnten, dass sich Fehler innerhalb eines einzelnen Code-Blocks ausbreiten.
Das geht zurück auf die Idee, dass alles, was Quanteninformation beinhaltet, anfällig für Fehler ist – und das schließt die circuits ein, die
selbst dazu gedacht sind, Fehler zu korrigieren. Das erscheint ziemlich problematisch, aber es gibt tatsächlich mehrere bekannte Lösungen für dieses Problem. Ich werde nur einige davon
erwähnen, aber keine davon im Detail erklären. Und übrigens, falls du den Eindruck bekommst, dass fehlertolerantes Quantencomputing
kompliziert ist und es viele Details zu beachten gibt, dann ist das durchaus verständlich, denn es stimmt. Es gibt viele bewegliche Teile
hier, und meine Absicht mit dieser Lektion ist nicht, alle Details zu erklären, sondern dir nur eine grundlegende Einführung zu geben, wie das alles
funktioniert. Eine Methode für fehlertolerante Quantenfehlerkorrektur ist als Shor-Fehlerkorrektur bekannt, benannt nach Peter
Shor, der diese Methode als Erster vorschlug. Die Idee ist, jede Syndrom-Messung mithilfe eines sogenannten Cat-Zustands durchzuführen,
was dasselbe ist wie ein GHZ-Zustand, wenn wir drei qubits haben, aber es kann auf eine beliebige Anzahl von qubits verallgemeinert werden, die dem Gewicht des Stabilisator-
generators entspricht, den wir messen wollen. Insbesondere funktioniert der hier gezeigte circuit zum Messen eines Stabilisatorgenerators. Und es kann
gezeigt werden, dass diese Methode nicht dazu führt, dass sich Fehler innerhalb eines Code-Blocks ausbreiten.
Sie erfordert die Erstellung des Cat-Zustands selbst. Und damit sie im Angesicht von Fehlern und potenziell fehlerhaften gates zuverlässig funktioniert, erfordert die Methode tatsächlich,
dass wir circuits wie diesen wiederholt ausführen und Rückschlüsse darüber ziehen, wo verschiedene Fehler während des
Prozesses aufgetreten sein könnten. Eine alternative Methode ist als Steane-Fehlerkorrektur bekannt, die erstmals von Andrew Steane vorgeschlagen wurde, und diese
Methode funktioniert anders und funktioniert nur für CSS-Codes. Bei dieser Methode führen wir die Syndrom-Messungen nicht wirklich an den kodierten Quanten-
zuständen in dem circuit durch, den wir ausführen wollen, sondern wir breiten Fehler absichtlich auf ein Workspace-System aus
und messen dann dieses System und erkennen Fehler klassisch. Die hier gezeigte Abbildung zeigt, wie das für X-Fehler gemacht wird, wobei die Workspace-
qubits anfangs auf eine Kodierung eines Plus-Zustands gesetzt werden. Das ist also im Wesentlichen eine
transversale Implementierung eines CNOT-gates, die nichts bewirken sollte, da das Ziel im Plus-Zustand ist. Aber wenn es
X-Fehler in den oberen qubits gäbe, würden sie sich auf das untere System ausbreiten und erkannt werden. Es gibt auch eine ähnliche Methode zur Erkennung von Z-Fehlern,
die hier nicht gezeigt wird. Es gibt auch eine verwandte Methode, bekannt als Knill-Fehlerkorrektur, die erstmals von Manny Knill vorgeschlagen wurde,
und sie basiert auf Teleportation statt eines transversalen CNOT, was es ermöglicht, für beliebige Stabilisator-
Codes zu funktionieren und nicht nur für CSS-Codes.
Das Letzte, was ich in dieser Lektion besprechen werde, ist ein sehr wichtiges Theorem, das als Schwellenwert-Theorem bekannt ist. Hier ist eine etwas informelle
Formulierung des Theorems. Es besagt, dass wenn wir einen beliebigen Quanten-circuit mit n gates haben, wobei n beliebig groß sein kann,
es möglich ist, diesen circuit mit hoher Genauigkeit mithilfe eines verrauschten Quanten-circuits zu implementieren, vorausgesetzt, dass das Rauschen
unterhalb eines bestimmten Schwellenwerts liegt, der unabhängig von n ist. Und außerdem ist es nicht zu aufwendig, dies zu tun, in dem Sinne, dass
die Größe des benötigten verrauschten circuits in der Größenordnung von n mal einer konstanten Potenz des Logarithmus von
n liegt. Das Theorem formal zu formulieren erfordert, spezifisch über das Rauschmodell zu sein, was ich in dieser Lektion nicht tun werde.
Es lässt sich zum Beispiel für das unabhängige stochastische Rauschmodell beweisen, das ich zuvor erwähnt habe, bei dem Fehler auftreten
unabhängig an jeder möglichen Stelle im circuit mit einer Wahrscheinlichkeit, die strikt kleiner als dieser Schwellenwert ist. Aber es lässt sich auch
für allgemeinere Rauschmodelle beweisen, bei denen Korrelationen zwischen Fehlern bestehen können. Das ist ein theoretisches
Ergebnis, und die typische Beweisweise lässt sich nicht unbedingt auf das übertragen, was wir in der Praxis tatsächlich tun würden, aber es ist dennoch ein sehr
wichtiges Theorem in praktischer Hinsicht. Und der Grund dafür ist, dass es im Grunde besagt, dass es keine grundlegende Barriere für die Durchführung von
Quantenberechnungen mit verrauschten Komponenten gibt.
Solange die Fehlerrate dieser Komponenten unter diesem Schwellenwert liegt, können sie genutzt werden, um zuverlässige quantum circuits beliebiger
Größe zu bauen. Anders ausgedrückt: Wenn das Theorem nicht wahr wäre, ist es schwer vorstellbar, dass groß angelegtes Quantencomputing
jemals Wirklichkeit werden könnte. Der formale Beweis dieses Theorems enthält viele technische Details, auf die ich nicht eingehen werde.
Aber ich werde versuchen, die Grundidee auf hohem Niveau zu erklären. Und ich werde auch versuchen, die Grundidee
lose mit dem zu verbinden, was wir in der Praxis erwarten könnten. Stell dir also vor, das hier ist unser circuit. Es ist derselbe circuit, über den
wir die gesamte Lektion gesprochen haben. Aber wieder können wir uns vorstellen, dass unser circuit deutlich größer und komplizierter als dieser ist. Wir möchten
diesen circuit implementieren, aber alle unsere Komponenten sind verrauscht. Und wenn wir das unabhängige stochastische Rauschmodell
der Einfachheit halber verwenden, gibt es eine Wahrscheinlichkeit P, mit der Fehler unabhängig an jeder möglichen Stelle auftreten.
Wenn der circuit deutlich größer als der Kehrwert dieser Wahrscheinlichkeit P wäre, könnten wir ziemlich sicher sein, dass eine
direkte Implementierung nicht korrekt funktionieren würde. Also durchlaufen wir den ganzen Aufwand der Implementierung des circuit
fehlertolerant, wie ich es bis zu diesem Punkt in der Lektion besprochen habe, und wir stellen uns die Frage, die ich früher aufgeworfen habe: Machen wir die Dinge
besser oder schlechter? Nun, wenn die Wahrscheinlichkeit P, die die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit für jede unserer Komponenten darstellt, zu groß ist, dann
wird das nicht helfen – genau wie der 9-Qubit-Shor-Code nicht hilft, wenn die Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit über ca. 3/4 % liegt.
Insbesondere haben wir den circuit jetzt größer gemacht. Also gibt es viel mehr Stellen, an denen Fehler auftreten könnten.
Wenn P jedoch klein genug ist, wird das helfen. Und was wir effektiv tun werden, ist, die Fehler-
wahrscheinlichkeit für die logische Berechnung, die wir durchführen, zu reduzieren. Lass uns das also ein
bisschen genauer betrachten. Und um die Hauptideen in einem möglichst einfachen Rahmen zu sehen, nehmen wir an, dass wir den 7-Qubit-Steane-Code zur Fehler-
korrektur verwenden, der die Korrektur von bis zu einem Fehler pro Codeblock erlaubt. Damit ein logischer Fehler
im ursprünglichen circuit auftritt, müssen bei unserer fehlertoleranten Implementierung mindestens zwei Fehler in denselben Codeblock fallen.
toleranten Implementierung.
Wenn man bedenkt, dass es viele verschiedene Möglichkeiten gibt, zwei oder mehr Fehler im selben Codeblock zu haben, lässt sich argumentieren, dass die Wahrscheinlichkeit eines logischen
Fehlers an jeder Stelle im ursprünglichen circuit höchstens C * P ^ 2 beträgt, wobei C eine Zahl ist, die vom Code und den
verwendeten Gadgets abhängt. Entscheidend ist jedoch, dass sie nicht von der Größe des ursprünglichen circuit abhängt.
Wenn P also kleiner als der Kehrwert von C ist – was die Zahl ist, die wir als unseren Schwellenwert nehmen können –, dann
führt das zu einer Reduktion des Fehlers. Unsere harte Arbeit bei der fehlertoleranten Implementierung des circuit zahlt sich
also aus. Aber diese neue Fehlerrate könnte immer noch zu hoch sein, damit der gesamte circuit korrekt funktioniert. Wir müssen also
mehr tun. In der Praxis ist es an diesem Punkt naheliegend, einen besseren Code und bessere Gadgets zu wählen, um die Fehler-
rate so weit zu senken, dass die Implementierung wahrscheinlich funktioniert.
Theoretisch gesehen ist ein einfacher Weg, zu argumentieren, dass das möglich ist, die Konkatenation. Mit anderen Worten, wir denken
über die fehlertolerante Implementierung des ursprünglichen circuit als neuen logischen circuit. Und dann implementieren wir ihn fehler-
tolerant. Und dann machen wir das wieder und wieder so oft wie nötig. Und es stellt sich heraus, dass das den Fehler
sehr schnell reduziert. Und so wird das Schwellenwert-Theorem typischerweise auf dem Papier bewiesen.
Ich gebe dir eine grobe Vorstellung davon, wie die Fehlerrate abnimmt, ohne die vielen technischen Details zu nennen, die nötig sind, um
das formal zu beweisen. Wir beginnen mit der Fehlerwahrscheinlichkeit P für unsere ursprünglichen Komponenten. Und wenn wir den
circuit fehlertolerant implementieren, sinkt der Fehler um einen Faktor C * P. Wenn wir dann unsere fehlertolerante
Implementierung als logischen circuit behandeln und ihn fehlertolerant implementieren, erhalten wir eine ähnliche Abnahme der Fehlerrate. Aber
wenn wir uns die effektive Fehlerrate für den ursprünglichen circuit ansehen, stellen wir fest, dass sie noch weiter sinkt, weil wir jetzt
die Fehlerrate P durch C * P ^ 2 ersetzen, da das die effektive Fehlerrate nach der ersten fehlertoleranten
Implementierung ist. Konkret finden wir nach etwas Algebra, dass der Fehler auf CP
hoch 3 * P sinkt. Und wenn wir es erneut tun, haben wir eine Fehlerrate von CP ^ 7 * P. Und wenn
wir das insgesamt K Ebenen fortsetzen, stellen wir fest, dass der Fehler doppelt exponentiell in K schrumpft. Wir müssen das also
nicht sehr oft tun, um die Fehlerrate extrem klein zu machen.
Gleichzeitig wachsen die circuits in ihrer Größe, aber die Größe nimmt nur einfach exponentiell in K zu, da mit jeder
Fehlertoleranzebene die Größe unseres circuit um höchstens einen Faktor wächst, der durch die maximale Größe
unserer Gadgets bestimmt wird. Und wenn alles zusammengefügt und eine geeignete Wahl für die Anzahl
der Konkatenationsebenen getroffen wird, erhalten wir das Schwellenwert-Theorem. Aber wie ich bereits angedeutet habe, sind viele Details nötig, um das formal zu machen. Also,
was ist dieser Schwellenwert in der Realität? Nun, er hängt vom Code und den Gadgets ab, die wir
für den Steane-Code zusammen mit der Magic-State-Destillation verwenden. Er ist winzig und wahrscheinlich in der Praxis kaum erreichbar.
Aber mit Surface Codes und modernsten Gadgets wurde er auf etwa 1 % geschätzt. Was gar nicht
schlecht ist. Und wenn neue Codes und Methoden entdeckt werden, können wir vernünftigerweise erwarten, dass er steigt, während gleichzeitig das
Rauschniveau in den Komponenten, die wir bauen, abnehmen wird. Den Punkt zu erreichen, an dem
groß angelegte Quantenberechnungen fehlertolerant implementiert werden können, wird nicht einfach sein und nicht über Nacht geschehen.
Aber dieses Theorem zusammen mit den Fortschritten bei Quantencodes und Quantenhardware, die wir bis heute erlebt haben,
gibt uns den Optimismus, den wir brauchen, um weiter voranzuschreiten und dieses ultimative Ziel zu erreichen: einen
groß angelegten fehlertoleranten Quantencomputer zu bauen. Und das ist das Ende der Lektion und das Ende der Serie. Ich
hoffe aufrichtig, dass du die Serie als wertvoll empfunden hast, und wenn ja, empfehle sie doch bitte einem Kollegen oder Freund.
Schau dir auch IBM Quantum Learning für weitere Kurse und Tutorials an und abonniere den Qiskit
YouTube-Kanal, falls du das noch nicht getan hast, damit du über unsere zukünftigen Inhalte auf dem Laufenden bleibst. Vielen Dank fürs
Zuschauen.